in this section
we're going to talk about the inner
product that's an operation
on vectors it's a very important one
that we're going to see
and use a lot in the course
so the inner product it's also called
it's got a lot of other names it's also
called the dot product that's a very
common name
in physics some people call it the
bracket between two vectors
but what it's an operation it takes two
vectors it takes a
and b two two vectors they have to be of
exactly the same size
and the inner product has a weird
notation that we're gonna understand
later in the course
uh it looks like a with a superscript t
uh and then a b and as i said later this
notation will become clear as to what it
means but here's what it is
it it's actually pretty simple you
simply take the product of the
corresponding
entries in the two vectors and you add
up you add up those products that's it
okay so um some other notation that you
would see would be
with these angular brackets that's
actually
very common you might see that with a
bar
in between another one is this that's
not very common and
this is the one where i think uh which
gave the operation its name you put a
dot
between a and b and i think in some in
some mathematical communities people
actually literally say a dot b
that's how they say it like to their
friends and stuff okay
let's do a quick example uh here's a two
three vectors
there's minus one two two and another
three vector is one
zero minus three and to take the inner
product of those two
vectors what we're gonna do is we're
gonna multiply the first entries that's
minus 1 and 1
then we're going to multiply 2 and 0 and
then we're going to
multiply 2 and minus 3 and we're going
to add those three numbers and so that's
going to give us minus 1
plus 0 and then minus 6 and sure enough
you get minus 7 that's the inner product
okay so that's that's the mechanics or
the plumbing of how you calculate an
inner product it's the
sum of the product of the corresponding
entries
right at the moment this should have no
meaning to you it will when we look at
examples
okay so here are some properties of the
inner product
and again like many of these things
these are extremely boring to work out
and stuff like that
but you do have to know you do have to
know these properties
and it's also very important to stay on
your toes here to
make sure that you understand each of
these equations
let me go through them a little bit and
maybe i'll audit one or two of them and
we'll try to see
what they are okay so the first one says
that
the inner product of a and b is the same
as the inner product of b and a well
that's clear because both of these are
equal to
you know a1 b1 plus dot dot
uh uh a n uh
b in okay now if i switch the order of b
and a then i'm just taking the products
uh instead of a1 b1 you're going to see
b1 a1
that's the same because two numbers you
can if you multiply two numbers in
either order you're going to get the
same thing
so this is the same let's take a look at
this equation and
what i mean by audit is you have to go
through and make sure you understand
what absolutely everything in it means
because it's very easy to see
something like that and just have your
eye go over and go yeah that's cool
whatever
but let's look at it more carefully okay
on the left
the first thing you see where my cursor
is you see gamma times a now here gamma
is a
scalar and so gamma times a is a scalar
vector
product right and so what's inside
what is inside those parentheses that's
a vector that's an n vector
and this says take the inner product of
that n vector with the vector
b that's the left-hand side so the
left-hand side is a number because when
you take the inner product of two
vectors you get a number
uh on the right-hand side we see
something different we see
first take the inner product of a and b
that's this term
here and then it says well that's a
number right
and then you multiply that by gamma so
interestingly gamma on the left
multiplies a vector
in the right hand equation it mult gamma
is multiplying a number
and what we're saying is that these are
equal now this is kind of obvious
because
this one here the first one says
multiply every entry of a
by gamma then multiply those entries by
b and add it up
you know and then this thing says
something like you know multi
take all the products of a i times bi
add those up and then multiply by gamma
well those are the same thing
okay and you'd have formulas like this
for example a plus b
transpose sorry getting ahead of
ourselves
i i let you know the secret of what that
notation is about and that's actually
something we'll cover later in the
course so
ignore that the inner product of a plus
b
and c uh turns out to be the inner
product of
of a and c plus the inner product of b
and c and again this
these are very easy to uh verify um
and you can you can get fancier uh
things like this this is a so-called
like
it's a distributive uh property right it
says
that if you take this is a vector sum
here
right and then you have to be very
careful because these are the these are
the sum of
real numbers right and so it says if you
have vector a plus b
inner product with c plus d that's the
same as as actually calculating all
four inner products of a or b with c
or d and then adding up those four
numbers and it's the same thing
okay so all right
um let's look at some very basic
examples and completely generic
um so this says that if you take the
inner product
of a unit vector with a vector the if
unit vector it just picks out that entry
well that's
easy to see because in fact e i
transpose a is going to be uh
well let's let's work out what it is
let's let's actually just do an example
let's take a
equals 2 1 -5
and let's consider e2 the sec the second
unit vector
of dimension 3 and that's 0 1
0. and then let's calculate e 2
transpose
a sorry inner product of e 2 and a
well that says take the product of these
two guys
product of these product of these now
that's a bit silly because
whenever you have a zero you're not
really i mean multiplying these two
gives you
zero multiplying these two gives you
zero the only one that gives something
non-zero is this and it's a one
so we get a 1 right and sure enough that
is exactly
a2 okay so that makes sense
here's another one if i take the inner
product of the ones vector
with a now the ones vector remember is
the vector with all ones
it says that you get the sum of the
entries of a
that's that's interesting okay
and another one is a transpose a that
says take the inner product of a vector
with itself
here's what you get well what you do is
you simply
take you take the products of the
corresponding entries but the
corresponding entries are the same
they're all
they're ai so you take those you get ai
squared and you add them up
so you get the sum of the squares of the
entries um that's also going to play a
huge role
in in the course moving forward right so
so that says that the inner product of a
vector with itself
is the sum of the squares of the entries
of the vector
okay so these are generic examples
let's see how they come up in practice
well let's take a look at this here's a
very common one
is let's suppose that f is a feature
vector
so it's got entries corresponding to
oh it could be let's say a bag of words
model so
each entry in f tells you it could be
from a dictionary it's a word count
vector it says that every
every entry of f tells you how many
times a certain word
appears in a document w is a weight
vector
and it's just a vector of numbers it's
got entries of numbers
w transpose f you could you could
interpret and in fact
people do interpret that as a score it
might be relevance
for example with large meaning it's
highly relevant and by the way if it's
small or negative it means it's not
relevant okay
so uh and then the the entries of w
are actually very interesting here right
because this thing
is going to be w1 f1
plus and then all you go over all of
these plus
wn fn right and so we can interpret
let's suppose that f uh
3 let's suppose that f3 is the number of
times
the word uh linear
appears in your document right then
if w3 tells you the weight on that word
um and if this was a search for things
relevant to like linear algebra
we would imagine that w uh 3 would be
a large positive number and that says
that the more times in your document you
say linear
the higher the score you assign that
document okay so
so this is just a generic example
here's another one price quantity so
here i have p is a vector of prices of
let's say
n different uh and different commodities
right so
p1 is the price per unit of commodity 1
pn is the price per unit of commodity
n q is a vector of quantities of those
of those products right so that's
sometimes for example it could be a bill
of materials that's the
that that tells you how much of each of
those
commodities uh you need or or
or how many of each of those things you
need
to produce one unit of something or to
complete one task
right that's a that's a bill of
materials and so if you take the inner
product p
transpose q or i misspoke again
inner product of p and q you're going to
get the total cost and
the reason is pretty simple that's equal
to sum
p i q i but that's beautiful enter
qi is the amount of uh commodity i that
you need
right in units right pi
is the price in dollars per unit and so
the product of these two
tells you sorry about that uh the
product tells you the uh tells you
how much that's how much you're going to
pay for commodity i
you add it up over all commodities and
that's your total cost right so
this is one where so inner product
between a price vector and a quantity
vector gives you a total cost
here's one from finance it's an
interesting one this comes up
all the time in finance and it goes like
this c is it going to be a
cash flow vector right so it's a it's a
cash flow
what that means is that c1 is the amount
that i
that you are paid now uh c2 is the
amount that you're played
paid in the next period let's say it's
yearly so a year from now
you get a payment c2 c3 is the amount
you're paid in two years and so on
okay then d is a discount vector and i'm
going to define it to be this it's the
vector that's
whose first entry is one one over one
plus r
one over one plus r squared and so on
and here r as an interest rate
like five percent or point zero five and
what this does is the first entry then
would be one
the second entry would be one over 1
plus r so that would be 1 over 1.05
which is about 0.95
and what the discount vector tells you
is really interesting it tells you
how much is a dollar paid in different
in different periods
how much is it what's the what is the
current equivalent
now right so people call that the net
uh present value and what this says is
that
if i promise to pay you a dollar in a
year and the interest rate is 5
that's worth about 95 cents right now
and you you can figure out why that is
because uh
it although i'm going to give you a
dollar it's going to be in a year
and the difference between having a
dollar now and a dollar a year from now
is if i had a dollar now
i could put it into the bank and earn
five percent um actually interest rates
right now are not five percent but
nevertheless
this is the idea okay so here if you
take
c transpose d or d transpose c sorry
inner product of d and c
inner product of c and d same thing what
you get is
uh you add up all the cash flows uh but
with the discounts
and you're actually taking all of those
cash flows and you're you're making it
what is the current value of that
in current dollars and that's going to
be that's called the npv
net present value of the cash flow okay
so
if you have a bond or something like
that or a mortgage or a loan anything
like that
if you simply do this if you add up the
discounted cash flows that's called the
net present value
okay last one example is also from
finance so here s is a vector that gives
you the portfolio holdings and shares
like suppose it's you know it's apple
google
and facebook fine um then
so for example if it was like 12 comma 3
comma 4 that tells you how many
shares of apple google and facebook you
have that's your portfolio
p is a vector of the same size in my
running example it's
it's three long and it gives you the
current price per share
of apple google and facebook right and
if you want if you take
the inner product of pns that's the same
as some
p i s i and here s i is the number of
shares
uh p i is the dollar dollar value or
dollar price per share
and when you multiply that p i s i is
precisely how much what's the
dollar value of your holdings in each of
these things apple google facebook
and you add them up and you get the
total value of your portfolio
okay so these are these are just some
examples but they should make it clear
that inner products do in fact come up
in many many applications
you